okay hi everyone
back for another episode of science and
technology
q a for kids and others
happy to answer all kinds of questions
here um looks like we still have a few
from uh lost
time left over we have one from anders
here
what is dark matter
well let's see when we look out into the
universe we see
lots of stars that we see uh producing
light and so on
question is is there other matter out in
the universe
that exists but that isn't producing
light that's
dark and how could we tell if it was
there
so we can tell if other things are there
is by looking at
the gravitational effects that they have
so
gravity makes things uh
is a force that pulls things together so
for example gravity is what causes the
earth to go
to stay in orbit around the sun it
causes our galaxy to stay together to
the hundred billion stars that are in
our galaxy
to to have them hang together and just
go around in a slow
spiral uh in this slow
rotation that they that they undergo uh
but but
hang together gravity is what makes them
hang together so the question then is
can we tell from the amount of gravity
that we see can we tell how much
stuff is there gravity the
force of gravity is depends on mass
depends on the total mass of stuff and
so can we tell what the total mass of
the stuff that's keeping the stars
going around our galaxy is and then
when we look at that total mass if we
compare that
with the number of stars that we see how
do those compare
okay so there's been this problem in
astronomy for
oh probably four decades maybe maybe a
little bit more than that
that when you look at the rotation of
galaxies
there seems to be more mass that's
holding in the things on the
outsides of the galaxy than we can
account for by just looking at the stars
in the galaxy
and uh so that so that that sort of
other stuff that seems to have a
gravitational effect but that doesn't
seem to be
showing up as stars we can see that are
producing light
it's called dark matter question is what
is dark matter
uh first question is is it really there
one thing that looked like it might be
true for quite a while
is that maybe we got something wrong
about the way that the force of gravity
works
but there are some examples where for
example we see galaxies colliding
going through each other where it seems
like there's a thing that got left over
that's dark
matter that's producing a gravitational
effect
but that isn't um that isn't something
that has
stars associated with it so what kinds
of things could dark matter be
well maybe it could just be additional
gas
that's hanging out between stars and and
just not lit up
maybe it could be little tiny black
holes maybe it could be some other some
kind of
particle some kind of matter that isn't
like uh ordinary protons and neutrons
and electrons that make up our ordinary
atoms
we don't know for sure uh there are lots
of different experiments that people try
to do to see what dark matter could
possibly be
and there's evidence and counter
evidence against various kinds of things
what seems to be the case is that
whatever dark matter is
it seems like it's not interacting much
with ordinary matter
because if it was then we would likely
see you know if it was little tiny black
holes then maybe we'd settle places
where there are
ordinary matter that are somehow
interacting with that black hole
those kinds of things it seems like dark
matter is something doesn't interact
much at all so there are a bunch of
experiments
that get done where people are trying to
look for oh maybe dark matter
is going through even deep in the earth
it's kind of going through some detector
that's under
two miles of rock or something it's
still getting through there or maybe
dark matter can be seen in this place
maybe it can be seen in that place
maybe dark matter is something
like a um uh it's it's
some kind of of a new kind of particle
that has a mass if it doesn't have a
mass
well could have a gravitational effect
because of its energy but but doesn't
really
doesn't have the kind of gravitational
effect that it looks like dark matter
has
so it probably has a mass but we don't
know what its mass is
and uh that's sort of the challenges to
figure it out
now for example in in our recent theory
of physics
there is some suggestion about what dark
matter could be
um because the theory kind of suggests
that there can be lots of different
kinds of particles like electrons and
muons and
tore leptons and so on we know about oh
around um
20 different kinds of of particles that
are currently thought to be elementary
the quarks
the the uh the things like photons and z
bosons and
and so on we know about 20 of these
kinds of things
um and uh this theory suggests that
there probably are a bunch more
and particularly ones that have masses
very small compared to the masses
of things like electrons that we see
today and so one possibility
is that those very low mass particles i
call them oligons
because they're oligos in greek means
few and uh they're particles that have a
very small
number of sort of atoms of space in them
and so these oligons would be a
candidate for what dark matter might be
um but we don't know whether that's
really what's what's what's happening
right now
uh quite possibly the dark matter that
we that exists in the universe
is dark matter that got created in the
very beginning
moments of the universe during the big
bang that happened 14 billion years ago
that started our universe and started
the expansion of the universe
um that was a time when sort of any kind
of stuff that could be produced would be
produced because
in the big bang things were the universe
was sort of infinitely hot
and that means that particles of all
kinds were getting produced
um in in substantial numbers
among them whatever dark matter might be
and
the dark matter could have been produced
and interact with things in the extreme
heat of the very early universe
but ever since then it's been not
interacting with things
uh so the um the question
of of um and so so some things get left
over
from the very beginning of the universe
for example the cosmic microwave
background
if you look in any direction in the sky
um you'll see
uh the the the sort of the photons that
were coming to us from
from the very early moments of the
universe well from about
10 000 years after the beginning of the
universe hundred thousand years after
the beginning
of the universe um are uh
uh that are that are the sort of
leftovers
of the sort of heat of the big bang same
with neutrinos
and same probably with dark matter so
that's the that's the current state of
dark matter and there's some interesting
kinds of physics
that people are doing to try and detect
the presence of dark matter
and to try and see when there's things
where it's just you just don't see
anything there you see some
effect from energy conservation momentum
conservation
or sometimes gravitational effects but
you don't see any other thing there
and that would be what one might call
dark matter now it's always suspicious
in science
you know if you say well what fraction
of the matter in the universe is dark
matter well it's about 90 percent
and that's always it's always suspicious
when when one comes up with conclusions
like that it's like saying you know
90 percent of the brain is unused 90 of
the genome is unused
mostly these kinds of science statements
end up not being true in the end
um that actually there is some uh that
there's there is some real thing that's
there
um we just didn't know how to look for
it there's another thing called dark
energy which is a little different from
dark matter
um dark energy is a weirder thing it's
almost
it's kind of like a negative mass kind
of matter
that is potentially leading to the
acceleration of expansion of the
universe
and it's a slightly more uh
controversial kind of thing
um also has a a potential source in our
models of
physics
all right uh let's see
um got a bunch of questions here's a
question here which i'm afraid i don't
know the answer to
uh oh maybe i do know the answer to this
question is why is the sun's corona
hotter than its core
um okay i will attempt this one
see this is where it's very unfair
because i'm i'm
if i was like allowed to use the web and
things but i'm not allowing myself to do
that because otherwise this isn't a good
conversation
so i'm doing all of this kind of cold um
the temperature of the center of the sun
i think is 10 million degrees
centigrade the temperature of the of the
luminous
part of the exterior of the sun is only
about 6000 degrees
but the corona which is sort of the area
around the sun
is is uh is hotter i don't actually know
the temperature
it's always a little bit tricky to
define the temperature of a sufficiently
rarefied kind of gas because normally
what is temperature you know when we say
this block of
metal is at this temperature this air is
at this temperature
what we mean is we're looking at all
those little molecules
in the thing the block of metal the air
whatever and all those molecules are
running around
and those molecules have a certain
average energy they have
kinetic energy associated with the
motion that there that they have running
around
and temperature is simply defined as the
uh in terms of the average kinetic
energy
um it's there's a constant called
boltzmann's constant after a chap called
ludwig boltzmann who lived in the late
1800s um
and he was the person who kind of uh uh
worked on on making the connection
between the microscopic
uh properties of matter and notion of
heat and temperature and so on and so
that constant
k it's usually uh is named after him and
and basically whenever there's a a thing
in a material
that can move around in a certain
direction there's a half
kt of of average kinetic energy
where t is the temperature that is
associated with that thing
at that temperature so for example a
thing that can move around in three
dimensions
there's three halves kt of average
energy
average kinetic energy associated with
that thing at temperature t
and uh so so in
in the case of the the when there's a
sort of rarefied gas
that is what is the corona of the sun um
i i don't um i think that the heating of
that
is associated with so so normally when
you have a
uh just some object out in the world
and you say uh it's it's hot whatever
how did it get its heat
how did that energy that's making all
those molecules run around
come to it well there are
several mechanisms for things to get
heat one is conduction
just you have a big let's say you have a
block of metal here you have another
block of metal
and the block of metal you just added
the second one is much hotter
than the first block of metal well you
can conduct heat
from one block of metal to the other
what that means is that the interface
between those two blocks of metal
there are little metal atoms that are
running around a very high speed
and they hit metal atoms in the other
block of metal
that are going more slowly and they
impart some of their momentum
to the other metal atoms and so those
start moving faster and gradually after
every
all these atoms have run into each other
and the thing has come to equilibrium
you will have taken the heat from this
one side and you will have spread it
equally
across all the parts of this metal
object and that's that process of of
of spreading heat by just having uh sort
of physical contact between the
materials
and um that's the process of conducting
heat conduction
that's one one way in which heat gets
transferred to things
another way in which heat gets
transferred is through radiation
so what that means is uh you can for
example
light from the sun can hit something and
those photons that are coming from the
sun they have a certain energy
and just like the uh the other atoms can
hit atoms and
and give them energy so those photons
from the light from the sun
can hit an atom and give it some energy
and therefore
you can increase the temperature because
you're increasing the average energy
because there's
there's energy from the light that is
being imparted being put into the energy
of the individual atoms
and that's some that's increasing
temperature that way
and so the kind of radiation that
can produce heat um is well uh pretty
much
any radiation um but among
electromagnetic radiation
um not only visible light but also for
example infrared radiation
um infrared is is what is typically
associated with sort of radiant heat
it's
it's
it's the typical uh frequency of photons
that is given off by things that we heat
up to maybe a thousand degrees
centigrade or 500 degrees centigrade or
whatever
the thing that causes heating elements
on a
oven or something like that to be um uh
to glow
um red we're seeing just the visible
light part of that
but most of the photons are infrared
photons that our eyes don't register but
those are still photons that are
con that have energy associated with
them and
they are what will heat up let's say a
block of metal or something
when those photons those infrared
photons hit the metal
they will kind of kick the atoms to go
faster and that's what heats up the
block of metal so that's the second kind
of way in which heat is transferred
is radiation now that kind of radiative
heating
photons are one way to get things hot
another is if you if you've broken off
an electron you've broken off a proton
and you're just accelerating that proton
and it's something that happens uh the
solar wind for example
is from the sun is is an example of a
place where
where electrons and photons and protons
rather
are accelerated by magnetic fields in
the sun and they stream outwards from
from the sun
and that's another kind of different
form of radiation
and that form of radiation can heat
things up too and i think that's what's
happening in the solar corona
is that um it's being heated by
uh the the energy associated with um
uh with these particles that have been
made
to get to this to the speed that they
get to
by magnetic fields by being accelerated
by magnetic fields rather than by just
being heated up by standard uh as a
standard
uh question of of the temperature of the
fame
uh just to round that out there's a
third kind of way that
you can transfer heat to things and
that's convection
and convection is something that happens
when when something is in a gas
and you say convection is
uh that there are atoms in the gas
molecules in the gas
that get heated up but those those
molecules actually move around so you
might have hot air
a block of hot air here and hot air has
a lower density than cold air so hot air
tends to rise
and so if we looked in this room we'd
see these little plumes of hot air going
up
cold air coming down that's the process
of convection
that is the transfer of heat because you
actually take these hot molecules these
molecules are running around quickly
and you're physically moving them by
this sort of stream of air is moving
them around
and that's able to transfer heat because
the hot stuff is moving to somewhere
where it can then transfer its heat to
something else and so
that's that's convective heating is when
you're
when you heat up air and then that air
is physically moving
somewhere else to heat something up that
it comes in contact with
and um in general you know when you when
you ask about uh a block of material or
something and you say
oh how quickly is it going to cool down
i've got my my cup of hot chocolate or
something
and i'm waiting for it to cool down
what's making it cool down well the the
number one thing that's making it cool
down is convective cooling
it's that there are molecules of air
that um
uh get that moving around in the air
they get in contact with the hot
chocolate the hot chocolate heats those
molecules up and then off those
molecules go
taking away the heat from the hot
chocolate and more molecules that are
colder come in
and and they get heated up again and so
that's why when you blow on the hot
chocolate
you're kind of getting more molecules to
move past the hot chocolate to get
heated up by it
um and uh um that uh and that's cooling
it down
so in fact there's a there's a thing
called newton's law of cooling it's
named after isaac newton
which says that the rate at which
something decreases its temperature
is proportional to the difference of
temperature between the thing
and the the outside environment
when you that's what happens when you
have so-called free convection when you
just have
the thing and there's just in still air
and
the heat of the of your of your hot
chocolate
is causing some air right above it to
get hotter
so that air has lower density so it
rises and
transfers away the the temperature the
heat associated with the hot chocolate
then new cold air comes in and then it
gets heated up and transferred away
and newton's law of cooling applies to
that situation if you blow on your hot
chocolate
you can actually i think you get a 5 4
slaw where the
where it's the temperature difference to
the power 504
um so it it cools down faster if you
blow on it and that's kind of why it
cools down faster if you blow on it i
mean this
this process of convection is common all
over the place i mean for example
inside the earth there are convection
currents
that are associated with the mantle of
the earth which is the liquid core of
the earth
has convection currents in it and
they're moving it goes they go quite
slowly
it's very viscous rock but it's it's
molten rock
in the center of the earth um and
the convection currents in the earth are
presumably what lead to the magnetic
field of the earth
they are they're moving things around
and they're they're presumably
uh like they they move also charge
around
and they produce a magnetic field that
is the magnetic field that we detect
when we have a compass or something like
this the sun also has
convection currents inside it um there's
a
a convective layer inside the sun it's
associated with stars of a certain size
sometimes you see really bizarre effects
i mean for example if you have
convection uh so so when you when you
look at the flow of a fluid
um if the fluid is flowing slowly and
you've got an object and fluid is
flowing
around it if it's flowing slowly the
fluid will just sort of slide around the
object and you'll see if you were to
look at kind of streams of fluid
you'll see that they're sort of smooth
streams of fluid flowing around the
object that's called laminar flow
um when the flow of fluid is faster
you'll start getting eddies
little vortices coming off behind the
object and when it gets even faster
you'll start getting this turbulent wake
where the where the fluid just looks
kind of random
okay in the case of um uh
of that's what happens when you just
have an object and you're pushing fluid
past it at a certain speed
the other thing can happen is that this
convection process
can cause fluids to move let's say you
have a a pan of
of water or something and you're heating
it from below
that heating from below will cause
convection to occur because again
just like with air the water that has
higher temperature
is a lower density it will rise the
water of
of uh that's colder will have higher
density it will fall
so you'll get these little convection
current convection cells going
where you'll have water going up coming
down going up coming down
and in the regime that's like the regime
where fluid is flowing past knowledge
and just sliding past and laminar flow
there's a similar regime for uh for
convection and actually there's some
really cool effects like for example you
can have this
hexagonal collection of of convection
cells where you look at the top of the
fluid
and you'll see these little regions
which are little uh hexagons packed
together
that correspond to uh the convection
cells
associated with little areas where where
the fluid is going up down up down et
cetera
um and the same thing is it's um
uh when just like in fluid flow
past uh an object when it goes faster
eventually you get turbulent flow the
same thing happens
in um uh in convection you eventually
get turbulent convection
um and there's all sorts of issues about
the rate of heat transfer and turbulent
convection
versus non-turbulent convection and so
on can talk about how heat exchangers
work
um all sorts of things like that but
anyway that's the basic story the
original question here had to do with
the temperature of the surface of the
sun
versus its corona um but uh i mean just
to say a little bit more about the how
the sun
works um the sun is powered by nuclear
fusion
um and uh it's it's powered by the by
ramming together hydrogen nuclei which
are protons
and releasing lots of energy associated
with fusion
um the uh uh it takes a long time
for even a photon to get from the center
of the sun to its
is i think about 10 million years for us
our star it's very
it's it's it's very slow because the
photon keeps on
uh it like hits something it hits
something else it hits something else
and takes a long time
for it to uh after all those collisions
for it to wind its way to the surface so
to speak
neutrinos uh go from the central sun
much more quickly
and the nuclear reactions that take
place in the sun also produce these
particles called neutrinos
which are particles that have that don't
interact
much with mata um they can a lowish
energy neutrino can go all the way
through the earth
without ever interacting and they're
hard to detect
but the fact that they go so far without
interacting means they can come even
from the center of the sun
and they are like a form of radiative
cooling they can take energy from the
center of the sun and they just
take it all the way out because this
neutrino which has energy
is like going all the way out of the sun
it doesn't it doesn't do sort of the
convective process
like the photon would do where it's
transferring energy to something
uh just by moving itself the neutrino is
just like i'm out of here
and it uh it exits the sun and um
uh and then then goes off into space
all right that was a long um answer to
that
let's see um
uh all right
there's a question um
here from uh
sarsa um are white holes theoretical
or are they real um uh
what about black holes uh what happens
to the light and matter that goes into a
black hole
okay so what is a black hole how does
this all work
so black holes are all associated with
gravity
so gravity is the force that causes
things to just fall
towards the center of the earth they
fall full towards
masses so gravity is what causes uh
massive objects
between them when we're dealing with the
earth
something the earth will fall towards
the sound of the earth okay
if you dropped something from a long way
away from the earth
and it was going faster and faster and
faster and faster and faster
um and uh there wasn't any atmosphere to
slow it down or anything
eventually it would go at about 25 000
miles an hour before it hits the earth
and the other way around if you want to
take something if you want to fire a
rocket
from the earth and have it escape the
gravity of the earth it has to go at
about 25 000 miles an hour
to escape the gravity of the earth so
what happens with a black hole is you
have enough mass
concentrated in a small region so that
the escape velocity is effectively more
than the speed of light
the speed of light is the fastest
anything can go
in our universe and so that means that
if the escape velocity is
is faster than the speed of light that
means anything
that gets close to the black hole gets
pulled into the black hole
and can never and and it doesn't that
nothing can escape from the black hole
so that's kind of the basic picture of
how black holes work
now then things get complicated because
the theory of black holes is to do with
einstein's general theory of relativity
and it took people 50 years to
understand
even that the mathematics that came from
einstein's theory
actually implied this phenomenon that
you could have this
area of space where things would kind of
fall in and not come out
okay now there's a lot of i mean we
understand
quite a bit more about this from our new
theory of physics
but essentially what's happening in uh
this picture of a black hole um
of of sort of things fall in and nothing
can get out because to get out you have
to be going faster than the speed of
light that's more or less a correct
picture
um the uh let's see how do i
get into this one of the tricky things
is
that in the mathematical theory of black
holes
the thing that's significant is the
so-called event horizon
that is the the the thing that the point
of no return once you fall into the
event horizon you can no longer escape
again
now the question is is that really
produced by
a collapsed star inside that's producing
a lot of gravity
or can the theory of gravity itself
have a sort of self-sustaining event
horizon like that and it's a little
tricky
because in the traditional theory of
gravity
the mathematical equations say you can
have this thing that just
exists in the vacuum it's just
associated with the curvature of space
in the vacuum
the gravity that exists in the vacuum
and all that has to exist at the center
of the black hole
is one point that has sort of an
infinite mass
that's a very weird thing and the
mathematics of it is similarly weird
it's a space-time singularity at the
center of the black hole that's all you
need in order to get a black hole in
order to get an event horizon
now in actuality in our universe when an
event horizon forms
it probably forms because you have a
collapsing star and there's a lot of
other crud
inside the black hole other than that uh
potential space-time singularity but you
can get a black hole
just from that one point space-time
singularity you can also get it by just
having a lot of mass
inside but because there's an event
horizon around it
you think well doesn't really matter
what's inside all you see
is what's going into this event horizon
well there's a whole big complicated
story in the theory of gravity about
whether there can be naked
singularities whether there could ever
be a singularity in space-time
that doesn't have an enclosing event
horizon and it's now known that such
things are possible
um and they but only in rather
restricted complicated circumstances and
very
weak singularities but uh
so you're kind of asking the question um
in a black hole uh okay so what happens
in the center of black hole
the space-time singularity if it really
has a space-time singularity what is it
what is that space-time singularity like
it's a very common kind of singularity
for a so-called schwarzschild black hole
and non-rotating black hole
is um uh um a uh
uh yeah that's a space-like singularity
and so uh what what does that mean what
it means is if you fall into the black
hole
and you're falling falling falling in
you're inside the black hole this is
kind of a weird thing to understand but
but basically you always fall towards
the space-time singularity
and every path that you might take
inside this black hole leads to the
space-time singularity
and you always reach the space-time
singularity in finite time
it can in your perception of time
it's like you only survive a certain
amount of time and then you reach the
singularity what happens with the
singularity
at the singularity time stops
now in our models where we're thinking
about the the progression of the
universe as kind of a computational
process it's kind of like
computation just stops it's like you
were a computer
and the computer died and its brain just
stopped the computations in it just
stopped
so it has no perception of time passing
because everything in it just stopped
and that's what happens in the center of
a in the space like singularity
at the center of the most common kind of
black hole
and as time simply stops uh the other
thing can happen is a time like
singularity where essentially you are
you are doomed to repeat things
infinitely repeat exactly the same thing
forever
but i think the more generic case is
probably that time simply stops
so the perception for anything that
falls into the black hole is time just
stops
eventually um and okay so that's
in a standard black hole you can kind of
see a movie of a black hole forming
and all the stuff is falling in and
eventually this eventualizing forms
and then you have a black hole okay
now you can ask yourself uh the standard
laws of physics that determine how
things work
are reversible in time so just like you
might see you know if you could see a
little movie
of of atoms colliding with each other
you could see a movie where these two
atoms come in and they bounce off
but the the reverse movie is equally
valid where those two atoms come in and
they bounce off the other way
when we look at things on a very large
scale we don't see that kind of
reversibility
that's a whole different story of the
second law of thermodynamics effectively
what's happening is
that even though we start with something
that's very organized
the actual process of all these
molecules hitting each other
is like doing a computation that sort of
encrypts what we fed in
and so we see something that looks kind
of random but but that's not what's
happening at a microscopic level in
physics in physics in a microscopic
level
people things are basically reversible
so
if there's a process where things can
fall in and make a black hole
you might say well isn't there a process
where things can well we can have the
exact time reverse of that
where we make a white hole where the
thing is spewing out stuff
um uh like uh in the time reversed
version of a black hole
well yes you can have that according to
the equations
of of gravity theory you can't have that
now the question is
can you actually form a white hole in
practice in our universe well that's a
whole different story
and the answer is probably not you can
no more form a white hole
then you can make something where you
have you know if you break an egg the
egg will be ill and or you shatter a
piece of glass
the glass will all be in pieces and
that's something you can see happen
but you don't see the glass
spontaneously forming itself from all
those shattered pieces into a nice
organized piece of glass that's the
phenomenon of the second order
thermodynamics law eventually increase
that's what tells you that doesn't
happen almost certainly there's a direct
analog of that
that says that white holes don't
spontaneously form in our universe
so a black hole of things sort of coming
together that's kind of like
uh that's that's like standard
thermodynamics running sort of things
forwards
a white hole will be kind of like the
reverse of that and it probably doesn't
happen in our universe
now there are things which could cause
white holes to exist so for example
in our theory of physics um the fact
that the universe
the universe is more or less
three-dimensional has space that's
three-dimensional i can move you know
forwards backwards left right up down
that's the three dimensions of space
in principle space could have six
dimensions or it could even have
2.7 dimensions or whatever in our theory
of physics
the dimension of space can actually vary
with positions so there might be parts
of the universe
that effectively have slightly different
dimensional space
we haven't seen that yet i just actually
was inventing a possible way to do
experiments to be able to see things
like that
um but any case the uh so one of the
things that could happen imagine there
was what
i'm calling a space tunnel which is
basically a
a lump of space that has more dimensions
than three
well it turns out that in that case what
you would see
is basically one one end of that space
tunnel would be a black hole
the other end would look like a white
hole it will be pulling in matter at one
end and spewing stuff out at the other
end
now if you ask what happens to the
matter that goes into a black hole what
is the fate of stuff that goes into a
black hole
well there are a lot of gravitational
forces in there which grind things up
but it's like do you actually get rid of
this matter or what what happens to it
well at first it seemed like everything
just fell into a black hole and then it
would
stick there and never come out then uh
well uh various people jacob beckenstein
stephen hawking other people
uh kind of figured out that there would
be
radiation from things like black holes
where
not only is um is there this was in the
early 1970s
this was figured out that uh quantum
mechanics
would imply that there should exist
would suggest at least that there should
exist
uh sort of radiation things that come
out of black holes
as well as everything falling into black
holes more or less the reason for that
is in quantum mechanics in a sense
there's a certain amount of uncertainty
in everything
and so among other things there's sort
of uncertainty about where particles are
and there can be uncertainty about oh if
there was this pair of particles that
got produced
did one of them is are they both on one
side of the event horizon did one of
them go on one side of the event horizon
one of them go on the other side of the
event horizon that presence of
uncertainty
will lead there to be particles that
sort of end up sort of randomly outside
the event horizon
and able to to go off and not not get
pulled into the not
not just get sort of ingested into the
black hole
so it's been sort of a mystery uh how
the ideas of quantum mechanics
relate to the ideas of the formation of
black holes it's a thing called the
black hole information paradox that you
can have sort of
uh information about about mata going
into a black hole
but then it never comes out again that
seemed quite mysterious and there are
slowly starting to be a few possible
solutions
in our theory of physics there's a very
clear solution to this this paradox
um it's a little complicated to explain
i mean i'll say the words that
go around it there's an event horizon a
so-called causal event horizon
there's also what we call an
entanglement horizon which is a
different thing
the entanglement horizon is the thing
that kind of limits the propagation of
quantum information
and the point is that the entanglement
horizon can be outside of the event
horizon
so it can be the case that there are
things that are trapped
that sort of matter that we don't we're
not we're not
we can't detect because of this various
features of this entanglement horizon
and there's also this event horizon
beyond which we really really can't see
what's going on
but there's there's this region between
the
event horizon the entanglement horizon
that can sort of maintain the
information of what
went into a black hole and when things
are getting radiated out of a black hole
it's believed that at the end of the
life of a black hole eventually
everything is radiated out
and the thing has a big explosion as so
it gets faster and faster as the black
hole gets smaller and smaller
and poof eventually there's no black
hole anymore um and that's as a result
of quantum effects but in our kind of
model
that happens because there is the the
information that went into the black
hole is trapped between these two kinds
of horizons
and so it can kind of happily come out
again when the
when the black hole evaporates that
entanglement horizon is a strange
quantum phenomenon
that comes out of our models and it's a
place where
uh it's a little bit of a strange thing
it's something where if you were
an observer if you were hanging out near
this entanglement horizon what would
happen is
that in quantum mechanics one of the
issues is
that quantum mechanics says many
different possible things can happen
but we have the idea that we can
eventually we decide we measure a
particular outcome
but that process of measuring an outcome
takes a certain amount of time
and at this entanglement horizon the
amount of time it will take to measure
an
outcome from a quantum measurement goes
to infinity
and that means that we can sort of never
decide we can never
make the measurement we can never
definitively decide did the particle go
into the black hole or not
and that's that's kind of how that works
ah let's see
gosh um
uh well let's see all kinds of questions
here all right we got a question
um from thoth asking
about is it possible to clone a dinosaur
um and how might that work
okay first of all uh what would it mean
to clone
a dinosaur well all life on earth
is specified by dna
sometimes it's a virus just rna but dna
this molecule
that is basically gives a program
for how to construct for example us
so like i have a copy of my genome the
uh
the sequence of of pieces of dna
molecules that exist in all the cells in
my body
it's about six billion base pairs long
base pairs of these agct
uh groups of of atoms that exist
on this long strand of dna
which is is the thing that encodes that
information so
what happens is this dna this program
for humans six billion base pairs long
this program basically says how to make
the molecules that we're made of the
proteins and things
that we're made of it says uh each gene
and there are about 30 000 genes in
humans um
where each gene is a certain piece of
that
long six billion base pair sequence in
our dna
and it says some genes are bigger than
others like there might be one that's uh
one megabase long one million bases long
and that or there might be one that's
only a kilobytes long or even shorter
than that
um but these genes are basically
specifying okay make a protein
that has units a g c t t t g a
c t t et cetera et cetera et cetera and
that
that protein is made the protein is made
in
with the amino acids the about 20 amino
acids
that are sort of the building blocks of
proteins and those
those base pairs specify the sequence of
amino acids that will be put together to
make each
kind of protein and so we have many
kinds of proteins you know actin in our
muscles
um cytochrome um uh
atp i mean lots of different things that
do different have different functions
um the uh the um
uh so so what our dna
is doing is specifying make these
particular proteins
and then these particular proteins are
when we grow
those are the proteins that are being
produced to
uh to make all the different things we
have the you know skin bones
eyes etc etc etc okay
so our particular um
uh so that's the the program that sort
of
specifies how to make us so when we talk
about
cloning things what we're talking about
is taking that program
and using it to build
a a new organism so if you were saying
you know let's clone this
cat for example you would take the dna
from your cat
and you would just take a complete copy
of that dna
and you would say let's make a new cat
based on the program for that particular
cat now
the other thing to say is between
different humans there's always a
variation in our base pairs there's
millions of
out of the six billion base pairs
there's many millions of base pairs that
differ
between humans and we typical we all
have about 700 000
base pairs that are pretty much unique
to us
us as particular humans because when
when our dna was originally
uh produced the um when when uh
you know when when each new organism is
is conceived the the dna
the process of making that dna has a
certain number of
random mutations in it um and
that and we also get
half the dna from uh mother half from
our father and so on but there's also
random mutations that happen even beyond
the mixing from parents
um so we each end up with a certain
amount of completely unique
dna that nobody else will have exactly
like that
okay but between if between
all humans most of our six billion base
pairs are exactly the same
if we look at a dog for example x six
billion base pairs will have all kinds
of differences from ours
now it's actually a little bit
embarrassing that i don't know what
fraction is for a dog but it's quite
possible 90 95 percent of the dna maybe
maybe a little less than that
um is shared between us and dogs there's
a lot of basic
functions of living organisms that have
very much
shared and have been pretty much the
same in the history of life on earth for
a billion two billion years
uh some of the basic things about how
living organisms work
are really the same across many
different organisms
but okay so let's say we wanted to make
a dinosaur
well what we would have to do is get the
program for making a dinosaur we'd have
to get the dna of the dinosaur
how would we get the dna of the dinosaur
well dna is actually a pretty robust
molecule
and it is conceivable that dna could be
maintained
in uh uh not decay over the 65 billion
years since dinosaurs disappeared
um and not um and that we might so there
was a
kind of an idea that wound up in in the
jurassic park movie i think
that was that maybe a mosquito would
bite a dinosaur
suck the blood of the dinosaur then the
mosquito would get
frozen in amber uh type of type of rock
and it will be stuck in amber and but
that molecule
the molecules from the blood of the
dinosaur containing the dinosaur's dna
will be in the mosquito
that have been sort of uh embedded in
the slump of amber and we'll be able to
break the thing open
take out that molecule and it's like
hello here we have a molecule
a dna program from a dinosaur okay
that's one possibility
there's another possibility was just
look at all the different organisms that
have evolved in the history of life on
earth dinosaurs pretty much
what were dinosaurs became birds
in the history of life on earth or so it
seems so the things you know
gradually there's evolution uh
the one organism will gradually uh give
rise to another organism as sort of this
moment when a separate species breaks
off
um it's kind of like an event horizon
forming in the physics of black holes or
something
they're there for a while everybody can
interact and everybody can interbreed
and then
then there's this kind of separation
that happens as uh
some members of a species become the as
you get a separate species of things
become different enough to break off
um and not be able to breed together
anymore but anyway so
if we look at the history of life on
earth there's this big complicated tree
of life
where all these different species all
these different organisms came into
existence
one thing we can do is say okay let's
look at everything
that was the successor of the dinosaurs
and let's try and figure out from all
these different things that came out
from the dinosaurs
can we work backwards to figure out what
the dna of the dinosaurs must have been
given that they led to this kind of bird
over here this kind of reptile over here
this kind of thing over here
you know let's pick put all those pieces
together and see what the common
ancestor that was the dinosaur must have
been
but okay so let's imagine that we've
successfully got and when we got
decent idea these days about what some
aspects of of dinosaur dna must have
been like but over time we'll probably
get more ideas about that
um as we are able to sequence more
organisms as we're able to
you know maybe we'll find that magic
mosquito i don't know
but um at least we'll be able to do this
sort of backward inference
of what dinosaur dna must have been like
okay so let's say we've got the program
for a dinosaur
how do we actually make a dinosaur well
it's a little tricky
because let's say you're cloning a cat
for example and people have
done that i think there's a there's a
there's a certain tendency to call that
a copycat
so to speak um the uh um
but in any case you you basically you
take well
the first kind of organism that was
cloned a mammal that was cloned was a
sheep called dolly um and uh dolly the
sheep
was this was in um the 1990s
um it's an interesting thing that for
many many years before that time
people had said cloning a mammal is
impossible and i
i used to ask why is it impossible
explain to me why it's impossible
people always say oh it's just too
difficult there are all these things
that can go wrong
etc etc etc the final procedure for
cloning a mammal
was really weird i mean it involves
basically electric shocks
to to cells and things like this it's
kind of like in the frankenstein
uh you know story or something but in
any case it was there was a procedure
found
for cloning even mammals uh and probably
work for humans too although people
don't want to try that
um the uh uh the sort of more junior
versions of that with with making
uh human organs and things that are that
are more interesting
but um uh the the thing that um
uh the thing that you do then is you you
have the program for dolly the sheep
and you want to actually make a sheep
from it well the good news is we have
other sheep
so we can take that uh dna that we have
from dolly the sheep
and we can make that into the the
fertilized egg
um that will be injected into a you know
this is in vitro fertilization
for a sheep so to speak um you're
putting the uh
the dna from dolly into the
the fertilized egg uh that is going to
grow into another sheep
and you inject that into a sheep and it
grows inside the sheep
and then you get a young dolly the sheep
um from from the you know you had
original
sheep and then you were going to make an
exact copy of that sheep
by taking dna out of the first sheep and
putting it into sort of in vitro
fertilization of another sheep and then
getting the results out
okay so notice there is an important
piece to this which is you
you have a fertilized you know sheep egg
and into that you put this particular
dna
that made dolly the sheep but you have
this fertilized sheep egg
so one of the problems is for a dinosaur
we don't have
a dinosaur you know if we try to make a
stegosaurus we might um well
uh we might say well what's the what's
all the stegosauruses
because they're reptiles had actual
external eggs they had eggs that
sat on the ground and eventually hatched
with little stegosauruses coming out
um and uh so you know what about the
rest of the stegosaurus egg
you know do we have the wherewithal to
make the rest of the stegosaurus egg
can we make um uh and and um and that's
a more challenging thing
we might be able to deduce backwards
what the dna of the stegosaurus was like
but do we have the egg
so what people have tried to start
thinking about is could we take for
example a chicken
which is a bird and um could we take
kind of a chicken egg
and could we somehow put our guess about
what dinosaur dna must be like
and somehow put it into a chicken egg
and and maybe the chicken is sort of
similar enough to a dinosaur
that the baby stegosaurus can happily
grow inside a chicken egg
as it could grow inside a stegosaurus
egg and if that worked
then eventually we'd have hatching
stegosauruses
and then we would have uh successfully
cloned dinosaurs
uh do i think this will eventually
happen yes i do
uh we will definitely eventually have
cloned dinosaurs
um and they will be uh uh you know
it's an interesting question how um
you know what good or bad things will
happen as a result of doing that
um but yes i think they will eventually
be cloned dinosaurs and
and yes you will probably whether you'll
be able to
go to a pet store and buy a uh you know
i don't think a stegosaurus would be a
great pet to have they got
they got really big um but they were
little dinosaurs too
um and so uh uh you know it's it's uh i
think
um the obstinate stegosaurus pet would
be a bad thing to have
a friend of mine has studied a lot the
dinosaur motion of dinosaur tails and
he's pretty sure
that some dinosaurs could whip their
tails around at supersonic speeds
so you don't want to be near a dinosaur
that isn't happy about what's going on
um but uh uh anyway that that's um so
yeah
i think that's a um that's something to
look forward to in the future
um oh my gosh so many questions
um
there was a question here from icy
about how do we tell i'm not sure if
this is a good one so
really cover but um there's a question
here about
how do we tell the difference between
science and pseudoscience
uh you know
people call things pseudoscience when
they believe that they're nonsense
um sometimes things that seemed like
they were pseudoscience
turn out to actually be science and
actually be true
and sometimes things that people thought
was pseudoscience turn out to be as
people expected nonsense
and it's uh it's often quite challenging
to tell the difference
because somebody can have an unlikely
theory for something
but it can turn out to be true and it
was just unlikely because everybody was
off thinking
something completely different was true
um
so you know there are so there are
there are particular areas where people
uh will say oh that's pseudoscience so
i'll give you one example
it's not so popular in the in modern
times but it's popular in the past
is um things like extra sensory
perception and telepathy
and so on so what's that about so you
know we communicate
by talking to each other we say
something somebody else hears it
we can communicate by gesturing around
and people can see what we gestured
but there was an idea at one point that
it was popular in the in
in up until oh probably 20 30 years ago
that there might also be direct brain to
brain communication
that might be the case that the
something associated with the thoughts
that we were thinking
would be transmittable to another brain
directly without us talking without
anything else
maybe it's some electrical process maybe
it's something it's not clear what it is
so so that was a that was a thing and
people studied it and the people did
all kinds of all kinds of things where
they would have one person in a room
who was looking at cards and they would
have another person outside the room
who was trying to think very hard and
try and imagine what card the other
person was seeing
by by virtue of this kind of extra
sensory perception this telepathy and so
on
and there was a lot of study of that and
how that worked and you know
was it what people guessing the cards
more often you would expect by chance
and so on
and in the end that looked like
pseudoscience because there was no
sort of significant effect that was
found but if we ask the question
could there be brain to brain
communication could it be the case
that the electrical uh signals that are
produced by our brains
are somehow detected by another brain is
that absolutely physically impossible
no it's not impossible i mean you know
after all we can perfectly well if if we
measure our brain waves we put an
electrical sensor on our heads and
we measure brainwaves well we can you
know there's a thing
outside of our brains that is sort of
extra sensorially
uh detecting what's going on inside our
brains
it's a big jumbled mess right now we
can't really tell
there's no good way to say oh let's put
an electrical uh
detector on our brain and say okay i'm
now thinking about a dinosaur type thing
we can't read out the information yet
about what our brains are thinking
although i suspect eventually we'll be
able to do much better at that
although one thing to realize is that
what's happening inside our brains is
probably really different for each
person
you know in human language the way human
language works
is that we're all saying the same word
to kind of mean the same thing
language is this kind of social thing
where everybody has to agree
that the word camera means the same kind
of thing but what's going on inside our
brains there's no reason
for the kind of way that i represent
knowledge inside my brain to have
anything to do with the way that
somebody
else represents knowledge inside their
brain there's nothing that is causing us
to communicate
directly the internal representation in
terms of electrical signals and so on
of knowledge from brain to brain but is
it possible that there could be some
sort of brain to brain communication
sure it's possible um is it uh
uh and you know when we look at
computers again if we looked at you know
if you if you take a radio
and you put it an old-fashioned like am
radio or something
you put it near a computer and i haven't
done this for a few years i don't
actually know what happens anymore
but it used to be the case that you
would hear
on the radio detect you'd be able to
detect the kind of the thought processes
going on in the computer you'd hear
nasty sound weird sounds
and as the computer does different
things uh you'd hear different
uh different signals and you know you
can you can often tell if you
if you make your computer do a lot more
work you'll hear the fan come on because
the computer will be using more power
and its fan will automatically try and
cool it down and things like this
you can you can there are similarly
electrical signals that differ depending
on what this is what the computer is
doing
just as presumably there are things in
our brains that
are different we certainly know that
there are things in our brains that
differ when you go to sleep
things like that we have different uh
brain waves and so on
so yeah so that's an example so
telepathy extra sensory perception is an
example of something
that is today firmly in the bin of
pseudoscience
will it turn out that it's a real thing
will it turn out that you know ants
really have that as well as being able
to lay down chemical trails for each
other will they in fact will it be
discovered that
you know the brain of an ant can
communicate directly with brain of
another knight
it's possible right now people would say
that pseudoscience
whether it will stay pseudoscience i
don't know sometimes there are things
that are in
in science so to speak that turn out to
be total nonsense
um and that people have believed for a
long time i mean there are a lot of
things
around um uh this pandemic where
we're we're getting uh you know more
aware of a lot of things in immunology
but people have said it never works that
way
but actually it does and we're
discovering that it actually works that
way
and so on so there are a lot of things
where people would have said oh no no
that's a
that's a kind of pseudoscience theory
but actually turns out it's not
so there's a it's a it's a bit of a more
complicated uh
you know interchange between sort of
science and pseudoscience than one might
think
and sometimes things can be believed as
science for 50 years 100 years
and it just turns out to be nonsense i
mean you know it was believed for a long
time that you know
the shape of one's head was an important
determiner of one's personality
i don't think people believe that
anymore but there were all kinds of
scientific studies that showed that
and uh you know it turns out to be
nonsense
um uh or to a large extent nonsense
and just like there are other things
where people believed that you know
the germ theory of disease the fact that
there was some invisible vector
that was causing disease to happen that
seemed like pseudoscience that seemed
like nonsense for a long time
until it turned out to be true so it can
be a complicated thing to tell the
difference between science and
pseudoscience
i would like to say that after all the
years of experience that i've had in
in doing science and trying to tell the
difference i i do better than the
average probably in that
i'm trying to think of an example where
i've been wrong um
about uh how things would come out there
um
there have been cases where i sus where
i thought the theory was a little bit
crazy
but it turned out to be right i wasn't
sure the theory was wrong
but it seemed more complicated than i
would have expected to be
to be the kind of theory that would turn
out to be right and it turned out it was
right
all right let's see gosh so many
questions here and i'm
running out of time um
ah let's see um
oh
there's a question here's a quite a
simple one in convection what drives the
flow of air and fluid in the first place
what drives it is simply that hot fluid
is lower density than cold fluid so it
floats
on top of the cold fluid so it's it's it
pulled up
by by the um uh by the cold fluid
and and convection starts up when fluid
is heated on a surface
and then then starts rising
um
let's see um
all right there are questions here about
some a few quite fairly simple ones is
there any possibility for the creation
of dark matter
in a fusion reactor like a tokamak
um
we don't know for sure but i'm guessing
the answer is no
and why do i say the answer is no if
dark matter was going to be produced
you would see processes go on
so dark matter has mass it has momentum
it has
energy so what you would see is you'd
see particles coming together
and they would uh particles come
together they have a certain amount of
energy
and particles go out and then there'd be
missing energy there'd be something
where you don't see what comes out
but you know it has energy because total
energy is conserved the energy coming in
is equal to the energy going out but you
only see some of the energy coming out
it'll be like a miniature version
of what we see in galaxies when we see
sort of the presence of dark matter
although that's more
gravitational effects this would be the
fact that there's energy
that is disappearing and it sort of
seems dark now
historically this kind of happened
before
because there were nuclear decay
processes nuclear beta decay
where we precisely saw things like
um uh you know another nucleus would be
produced an electron would be produced
and it'd be whizzing off in some
direction
and it's like how is momentum conserved
in this case we've got this electron
whizzing off in this direction
and there's nothing compensating for it
sort of going the other way
well that's what led to the invention of
neutrinos
the the realization that there was
another kind of particle it was just
something we couldn't see
it seemed like kind of a dark matter
kind of thing
i it's a particle that has no charge it
doesn't interact electrically
it has only uh so-called weak nuclear
interactions
um and neutrinos are very weakly
interacting things they can often go all
the way through the earth for example
um and so that's an example of of
something like
a sort of previous version of something
like dark matter
that um uh existed uh
that exists in the universe and so
people have certainly looked for dark
matter
where it's like some process happens
with particles colliding and have a
certain amount of energy and whoops we
missed the energy
people have looked for that and haven't
seen that so that's a that's evidence
that doesn't happen often at least
so i think that probably is not a
process that can make um
dark matter but um i i you know it's an
interesting question
and maybe it can make it as small um uh
at a small rate
all right i am supposed to go to
something completely different now but
um
i am just this is so much fun i'm i'm um
uh oh gosh there's so many questions i
want to
uh want to answer here so there's one
from william here
why is the moon the same size as the sun
when seen from the earth
that is really a coincidence uh
eventually it will be smaller
the moon is gradually moving away from
the earth and eventually
it will uh not be you know right now you
hold out your thumb i don't know whether
this is uh
and you can more or less cover both the
moon and the sun uh with the with the
angle that you get to
um you know in um uh
i think in babylonian times they used to
measure angles on the sky by such and
such a number of fingers
um you know when you hold your hand out
at a certain at that sort of uh
your fingers are a certain size there's
a certain angle there but any case
so right now for we are the unique
planet in our solar system where
the um actually i don't know this
absolutely i think we're the unique
planet where a moon
of ours and we only have one moon uh
just exactly
covers the size of the of the disk of
the sun which is why when you see a
total solar eclipse
i've seen two in my life they're really
cool worth going to see them
um the you know the the moon when it
moves in front of the sun
just exactly covers the the sun they
more or less exactly match in size
um if we're on mars for example the
moons of mars phobos and demos
are tiny compared to the disk of the sun
on mars
um and uh the um
uh so in time so be be glad you live at
this time in history
you know in another uh in another
probably even another
50 million years 100 million years uh
you won't be able to see nice total
solar eclipses on the earth that that
same way
because the moon will move too far away
but i think it's sort of a coincidence
of current times
but that's what we see uh
all right well i'm so
um
oh boy there's a question here this
one's easy to answer
uh the question what do you do for fun
for me this is a good example of what i
do for fun
this is fun for me uh it's uh
um uh what else do i do for fun
i i do science for fun um
i uh i do
i'm a tech ceo for fun i kind of like to
do the things that i like to do so to
speak and i've kind of
tried to arrange things so i get to
spend as much of my time doing things i
like as
as possible and
usually i at times i develop various
kinds of hobbies
and somehow almost every hobby i've ever
developed has eventually turned into a
real thing
so i kind of had hobbies of studying
history and i've written some
some some books about kind of um uh
you know the book of like a book of
historical biography and things like
that
and i you know that ends up becoming a
thing that i do
um i don't know what's going to happen
to this particular hobby that has been
uh sort of originally i i started doing
these um
q a's uh because i wanted to uh
uh uh help out in in the pandemic but
they're really fun and um this is what i
an example of the kind of thing i do for
fun
and um i'd better go
and um uh do some day job
tech ceoing because that's the next
thing that's up on my agenda
actually talking about um uh
um an initiative that um
we are going to be pursuing as the
pandemic
continues uh in education and maybe i'll
talk about that another time
all right well thanks very much uh see
you again next week
and um i'll try and uh cover some of the
questions that came in here
and i didn't get a chance to to go
through next week so
please tune in again thanks okay bye-bye